c'est vrai que je lui disais à la
pendant le sujet et c'est vrai j'avais
20 ans de télé donc j'en ai beaucoup vu
des gens je commençais à dire un peu
dans les yeux euh je crois sincèrement
vous êtes un homme très très gentil
alors il faut simplifier quand même du
mot gentil aussi parce que connard il y
a gentil on n'est pas loin de un peu con
hein
c'est que quand par hasard vous avez
comme par exemple vous avez dit j'ai
refusé de faire les grosses têtes je
sais pas que j'aime pas Laurence c'est
très bien et tout ça mais juste par par
amitié pour Philippe Bouvard un
animateur qui va pas prendre un cachet
et qui va pas se mettre à l'antenne
juste par respect pour l'ancien
animateur j'en connais pas lourd moi ça
me semble être la moindre des choses
maintenant
peut-être oui je sais pas mais ça me
semblait évident en tout cas de réagir
comme ça moi je ferai pareil Hanouna
s'en va à sa place du tout
où je peux vous dire que
ah non ne croyez pas ça non euh
tu pourrais la prendre
petit matin weekend oui à 6h et
j'appelle vous habitez CANNES oui alors
je partage ma vie entre Paris et Cannes
et Isabelle peut en témoigner parce que
on se voit on se voit à peu près tous
les jours donc on a bossé ensemble et
puis nos bureaux sont juste à côté l'un
de l'autre quasiment j'ai pas en fait je
partage ma vie professionnelle et ma vie
personnelle avec ma femme et mes deux
enfants j'ai j'ai une femme merveilleuse
et deux enfants de 10 et 5 ans donc il
faut quand même être un petit peu là et
comme je l'ai dit à Jordan l'autre jour
un jour je voudrais Jordan
c'est un ami un ami comme ça et je lui
ai dit c'est vrai que j'aimerais pas un
jour arriver chez moi faire toc toc à la
porte et que mes enfants disent vous
monsieur quoi ça m'embête un peu donc je
dis vous êtes un mec bien il faut
essayer de partager sa vie et je fais
des allers-retours je suis la ligne
Paris-Nice me connaît assez bien
heureusement vous avez quelque part j'ai
travaillé un peu là j'ai les boîtes
libertines j'ai tout ça mais c'est vrai
que sinon c'est un peu ah oui mais sinon
on va pas y arriver les gars non je vais
vous poser une question très honnête
est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez en
télé la carrière que vous méritez alors
je ne sais pas c'est dur de répondre à
ces questions en tout cas je crois que
j'ai la carrière que j'ai voulu ah oui
parce que un moment donné pour tout vous
dire après avoir passé un petit peu plus
de 20 ans à faire de la Télé Matin Midi
et Soir parfois même en quotidienne
l'été l'automne l'hiver le printemps
l'été sur les plages le reste du temps
je reconnais qu'à un moment donné j'ai
commencé à 17 ans quand même la
télévision et j'ai saturé un peu et
j'avais une envie de liberté une envie
de faire du dragster avec mes potes j'ai
découvert le milieu extraordinaire de la
liberté de la radio mais là c'est pas
possible vous étiez vraiment dans la
lignée c'était en plus une télé à
l'époque très gentille après c'est un
peu violenté avec les faux gel tout ça
et elle redevient bienveillante
maintenant donc à mon avis et je
souhaite votre à votre retour mais c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque vous étiez dans les
nids des Drucker des des Cyril férauds
vous étiez vraiment pour faire ça eux se
sont installés sur le temps vous il y a
eu des émissions sur France 3 il y a eu
des essais sur TF1 avec mouchou patamo
aussi l'été l'émission des records aussi
40 degrés mais ça a été présenté par
plusieurs animateurs si on est très
honnête on vous associe pas une émission
vous vous connais tous et on n'a pas
réussi à vous accrocher on va dire mais
je crois que à ce moment-là ce qui était
vraiment sympa dans cette espèce d'âge
d'or de la télévision c'est qu'il y
avait souvent des projets extrêmement
intéressants c'est à dire que un jour on
disait tiens tu veux pas présenter les
prime-time de Tintin avec l'arrivée des
dessins animés est-ce que tu veux pas
faire les missions des records est-ce
que tu veux pas aller sur les émissions
de magie partir à Las Vegas avec David
Copperfield ça ça fusait vraiment je me
suis amusé comme un fou à ce moment-là
et j'ai senti nettement l'histoire de la
télé Isabelle la connait bien
au moment où moi je commençais à saturer
c'était l'arrivée de la téléréalité puis
on m'a dit tu veux pas commencer à
présenter
je sais plus comment ça s'appelait parce
que tout n'a pas abouti dans les
maquettes que j'ai pu faire on a même
l'émission ou l'émission de Nagui sur la
chanson j'ai fait les paroles voilà j'ai
fait une première maquette il y a une
quinzaine d'années avec Nagui qui
produisait et puis finalement ça a pas
abouti tout de suite j'ai senti en fait
que cette télé qui arrivait me brancher
moins par rapport à la société de
production que je voulais monter pour
faire des documentaires sur le cinéma et
devenir enfin réalisateur ce dont je
rêvais quand j'étais gamin faire plus de
radio etc parce que quand on vous voit
vous êtes tout gentil tout doux tout et
quand vous étiez petit alors on a deux
points communs on est fans de Belmondo
et on a perdu à nos parents à 9 ans vous
écoutez la radio il y avait un crédit
qui critique radio qui critique le
cinéma ça vous amusait pas vous prenez
le téléphone pour l'engueuler et vous
avez fini par rencontré dont vous étiez
téméraire quand même oui bah c'est vrai
que le but c'était d'aller de l'avant et
je me disais que cinéma
je suis sûr que j'aurais été hyper
mauvais moi je voulais faire de la
réalisation être derrière faire du
montage éventuellement diriger des
acteurs mais c'est vrai que vous en avez
plein d'autres sur Godard donc sur
Belmondo ouais est-ce qu'on peut revenir
un petit peu sur la télé parce que moi
40 degrés c'est l'émission vraiment si
on a une qui doit revenir à la télé pour
moi c'est 40 degrés à l'ombre de la
moyenne émission quand même 42 degrés à
Londres c'est un peu incontournable je
savais qu'on continue à beaucoup m'en
parler bien sûr et puis toute la
séquence séduction les deux
si vous avez reçu Jean-Claude Van Damme
et ça c'est mythique
à 2 minutes pour le séduire et je trouve
très charmant mais je suis sûre que
derrière le bel homme que vous êtes se
cache un homme romantique et sensible
vous avez fait de la danse je crois 4
ans de danse classique
[Musique]
arrêtez vraiment ça me je suis très émue
ça c'est très gentil ça je suppose
qu'après un entraînement vous aimeriez
vous faire masser vos muscles ça serait
vraiment un des plus grands plaisirs que
vous puissiez me faire très gentil
j'adore les massages c'est super ça fait
énormément de bien que je crois
alors il y a pas l'extrait aussi où il
fait le grand écart je sais pas si on a
celui-là aussi
le coup de pied qui m'est passé un
centimètre du nez et tout ça oui et
c'était assez impressionnant mais
c'était quand même une télé absolument
incroyable de liberté à ce moment-là
passer deux heures de direct par jour
sur les plages pendant tout un été c'est
se permettre tout ça et avec des stars
qui jouaient le jeu parce que c'était
quand même déjà une très grande star
Jean-Claude Van Damme vous faites partie
de ces gens qui pensent aussi que voilà
la télé de façon aujourd'hui
évidemment que c'est plus comme avant
mais non non je pense pas être vieux con
encore vieux je le deviens con j'espère
pas trop mais non en revanche je crois
que je suis conscient d'avoir vécu une
période assez géniale de la télé où il y
avait pas de problème de moyens où on
pouvait faire avoir des idées débarquer
dans le bureau du directeur des
programmes en disant je propose ça les
émissions tous les sphères en l'espace
de 3 minutes aujourd'hui tu es convoqué
dans le bureau du direct
je te le dis non mais c'est vrai est-ce
que il y a il y a est-ce que est-ce que
vous aimez Vincent Lagaf' en tout cas
c'est un très bon copain on a fait plein
de choses ensemble on a fait du jet-ski
ensemble oui oui c'est un très bon vous
êtes sûr de ça pourquoi il m'a démonté
qui était une sorte de jeu de loi un été
super moi j'avais adoré sur l'été qui a
pas très bien marché le bagarre le
Lagaffe est allé derrière dans le bureau
et il a dit moi je te fais un jeu deux
fois moins cher ça va s'appeler Laura
l'appel et c'est je te fais juste
prendre la place je me souviens je me
souviens de ça mais je pense pas que
c'était dirigé contre moi parce que
l'histoire de mokchup mais non Matthieu
pâte à mousse c'était pour deux mois
c'était signé pour deux mois c'était
produit par Gérard Louvain et le décor
qui était un décor immense unique au
monde partait en Allemagne après et on
savait qu'en commençant on s'arrêtait à
la fin de l'été mais après que Vincent
est peut-être avec un peu d'opportunisme
et de professionnels eddy est vendu à la
chaîne
je pense qu'il a il a il n'empêche qu'on
s'entend bien non non vraiment vraiment
souriant je vous écoute à la radio
parfois le soir chez Eric Jean-Jean vous
êtes vous êtes cultivés en cinéma
incroyable vous faites des docks c'est
vrai que vous avez l'air très heureux et
que parfois on se dit dans la télé ouais
il faut malheureusement dans la télé
parfois faut écraser quelqu'un
j'ai la vérité je l'ai pris là il
voulait animer et il y a qu'une émission
mais vous êtes oui je peux citer un truc
une émission qu'il a faite qui était
géniale à la quête j'ai eu la chance de
participer que Carole Rousseau voulait
reprendre ça s'appelait c'est pas juste
un gamin devenait dire un projet qu'il
avait il y avait un juré qui jugeait de
l'intérêt du projet du gamin et qui
l'aidait le
aussi surtout belle histoire d'amour
avec l'alsa Minelli oh c'est ça quand
même alors c'est bon
avec une perruque on peut tout te dire
Vincent maintenant bon je suppose qu'il
faut que j'en dise un petit mot
prescription alors une belle histoire
d'amitié qui s'est transformée en une
petite idylle si vous voulez voilà c'est
ça mais en fait grâce à mon à mon pote
qui est mon grand frère Pierre Billon
qui a écrit beaucoup de chansons pour
Johnny pour Sardou et cetera et qui
était un grand ami parce qu'il avait
fait ses études aux États-Unis de l'alsa
Minnelli on a fait pour la 3 une
émission ensemble qui s'appelait
recherche Liza désespérément et puis on
a passé pas mal de temps et la passion
du cinéma puis moi j'étais un
inconditionnel de son père Vincente
Minelli et de et de sa mère Judy Garland
et puis on parlait beaucoup de ciné elle
m'a emmené sur des tournages de films
etc etc et puis et puis et puis et puis
et puis voilà et puis c'était
super c'était super mais deux derniers
mots vous êtes fan de vraiment de shots
j'allais dire parce que vous faites du
dragster oui je faisais je faisais
j'étais jeune le record 530 km/h en 250
m c'est ça exactement 3 secondes 6
d'accélération
à ton grand-père c'est à dire que tu
prends 20 ans l'espace de 3 secondes et
demi
[Musique]
tu retard de l'émission c'est vrai qu'il
a raison Thierry non mais quand même tu
vois
ça c'est 10 ans de ma vie extraordinaire
j'ai un dernier on va vous demander on
m'a dit que j'étais autorisé
en ce moment il y a toute la faire
Palmade qui fait parler mais plus que
l'affaire Kennedy
on m'a dit que vous le connaissez un
petit peu c'est quoi votre votre avis
sur moi Pierre je l'ai vu arriver en
tant qu'humoriste on a commencé nos
carrières à peu près au même moment on a
fait un nombre incalculable d'émission
ensemble on se connaît bien on était
proche il y a des choses qui nous
séparent et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui nous
a un petit peu éloigné ces dernières
années tout le monde me l'aura compris
cette affaire est un drame absolu je
peux pas m'empêcher de penser à cette
femme enceinte je peux pas m'empêcher de
penser à ce petit garçon je peux pas
m'empêcher de penser à son papa et je
peux pas m'empêcher de penser à Pierre
qui a fait là la plus grosse connerie de
sa vie et je pense qu'il va la payer
longtemps pour toujours ça suffit
ou pas du tout ou rien je l'ai vu pas
longtemps avant en plus on s'est vu aux
Grosses Têtes on Laurent Ruquier m'a
invité comme invité mystère pour la
sortie de mes jeux de société popopop
c'est aujourd'hui vous en pensez quoi
pardon ou ses amis qui le lâchent
aujourd'hui vous en pensez quoi est-ce
que dans ces cas-là il faut soutenir un
ami il faut lâcher je ne sais pas si ses
amis le lâchent ou ses amis refusent de
prendre la parole moi j'ai absolument
rien voulu dire nulle part et je pense
que ne pas prendre la parole c'est aussi
lui rendre service parce que que
voulez-vous dire qu'il ne soit pas à
charge bien sûr donc on me l'a demandé
20 fois j'ai vraiment le seul à qui j'en
parle et je vous remercie parce qu'en
plus il était prévu qu'on se voit avant
le drame mais il y en a bien assez comme
ça tirons pas sur l'ambulance c'est
suffisant c'est suffisant et je vous
remercie beaucoup parce que j'étais très
très heureux de vous rencontrer c'est
sincère c'est des années que je vois et
que je ressens cette gentille monsieur
j'en suis persuadé si vous vous revenez
à Télé revanche serait très content
d'autres
donc la promo effectivement je pop pop
vous avez créé deux nouveaux jeux dédiés
à la pop culture au cinéma c'est un pro
de station de jeans est mort vous êtes à
votre maison compulsif passionnés de pop
culture vous retourne sur RTL samedi et
dimanche voilà et j'ai une chaîne de
cinéma Mathieu qui s'appelle pop sinoch
sur tous les réseaux sociaux avec tous
les jours des photos des magazines des
interviews abonnez-vous ce soir et on
est sur les petits textos avec grand
plaisir et ben merci beaucoup merci
d'accueil